[Music]  is there anybody inside there tonight  that you say I've got to meet that I  haven't that you're really like looking  for yeah honestly I didn't okay so how'd  it be okay no I know that she is like my  lover  we all are obsessed like make a sound  okay so you'll have an app we see it on  Instagram with her yeah I'm gonna make  okay if I meet her tonight I will make a  video making a sound  it'll be amazing unfortunately for Milly  cardi B did not attend the time 100 gala  in NYC as planned Tuesday night but  we're sure there will be many more  opportunities for these two powerhouses  to meet the country count Millie is also  back to work on stranger things  they just started production on season 3  how was the table read every was great  it was great episodes were amazing I  love how you're choosing to choose your  words very careful we just home  yesterday just from the first day and  it's very exciting and the viewers are  gonna be very  [Music]  [Applause]